and I'm wondering what your take is on
rejection because it doesn't feel so
great
I don't want rejection but I embrace it
just like failure um
failure and rejections are signposts
telling you that you're doing something
right if you're not being rejected and
you're not failing you're not moving
forward because no matter who you are or
what you do you will encounter rejection
and failure
the difference is do you stop or do you
move forward and learn something from it
have you always thought like that was
there ever a time that you did let
rejection kind of go to your head and
you and you ruminate it over it yes as
much as I you know preach this stuff and
attempt to integrate it into my own life
hey I'm human and I got smacked around
and it doesn't feel good and sometimes
yeah sometimes it gets in you and you
start to have self-doubt and you start
to wonder what you're doing why you're
doing it all these kinds of things but
the trick is to experience it which is
fine and then let it go and from there
you can move forward
another thing that Kelly said in your
interview with her and maybe we can put
a link to it underneath this video
because I recommend it people to watch
it sure she's talked about working this
corporate job and I think her dad was
like a VP or he was a successful guy and
she felt that pressure to follow and
then she just realized I might be making
a lot of money but I'm not happy have
you ever been in a similar situation
where you realize that time for money
equation and you realized that time was
was worth more yes
so I'm recently on to a new thought
which I got from my pal Tony Robbins now
a huge life coach okay so Tony has been
hugely successful in his life and he has
the thing which he calls
the science of achievement okay and he
believes that you can figure out how to
emulate people who have been successful
and if you do this you will be
successful and it's basically true
however he also realized after many
years decades of doing this that it
doesn't matter how successful you are if
you are not fulfilled so that's the
other part that is the art of
fulfillment okay
so it's really important to remember
these two pieces and keep them balanced
so for instance in my former career
doing music for film and TV I did a lot
of music I love music and you know I was
pretty successful with this that was
going well and then at some point I
realized hey my music my love my heart
sorry my heart is now the background
music for some dopey TV show so it was
successful but it was not fulfilling and
that is when I decided I do not want to
pursue this anymore it's not fulfilling
to me even though it was paying so I
sort of changed tracks so there's a lot
of you know depending on what you're
doing and who you are what is your
fulfillment and what is your success and
how do you balance this - how did you
decide to leave that because I'm sure it
was probably you know it's supported a
lifestyle mm-hmm
how did I decide it you know there's a
lot of ways to make decisions and the
way that you make decisions will
completely inform the direction of your
life
okay I'm one of like the logical way to
make decisions as to sort of put the
pros and the cons together you know and
just sort of decide based on a logical
way to go but that's only one way to
decide there's another way to make
decisions
which is more of a heart centered
approach right which often defies logic
but it is really what the core it's the
core of who we are and what we're about
right what you love what you know in
your heart is way bigger than what your
little brain spins around a million
times in a row trying to figure out you
know then the sort of neurotic self-talk
and all that stuff everybody's got it
and it doesn't really do you much good
most of the time it's just this big spin
in a circle if you can make a decision
based on what your heart knows is true
you will align yourself with a higher
purpose and you'll make whatever
decision you need to make and I suspect
in many ways it will turn out for the
better I know Steve Jobs I believe was
quoted as saying he felt that getting
fired from Apple before he formed next
was one of the greatest things that
could happen to him at that time but he
didn't realize it then nobody realizes
it it hurts you get rejected you fail
you get fired you end up on the curb
whatever the deal is nobody likes that
stuff it hurts but the trick is and
Steve Jobs clearly understood this and
and many people do if you can learn from
your failure and learn from your
rejection you will step it up that's all
it is it's your best teacher
you